on commence enfin à voir à quoi
ressemblera le nouveau pont champlain
ces piliers sont maintenant tous
installés la scène est d'ailleurs
impressionnante lorsqu'on roule sur le
pont actuel au sommet de la voie
maritime
le grand pylône central de la future
partie au ban et atteint maintenant 100
mètres de hauteur il atteindra 170
mètres en juillet et sera plus haut que
le match du stade olympique
puis un peu partout on a commencé
l'installation des 37 chevet trop déçu
des piliers et des 600 poutres caissons
comme celle ci qui vont soutenir les
dalles du tablier
on a 35 % des travaux à terminer en 2018
on aurait préféré avoir seulement 30%
complété pour aller plus vite le
consortium engager plus de travailleurs
ils sont maintenant 850 à travailler
jour et nuit presque 1000 avec les sous
traitants
des discussions sont en cours avec
ottawa pour savoir qui paiera la facture
supplémentaire
l'échéancier prévu dans le contrat est
toujours le même on est très confiant d
ouvrir le pont de 102 me tuer tsé-tsé
seul objectif est ce que ça va être
facile ça demain à port mais tout le
monde et l union
le consortium a intérêt à réussir des
pénalités de 100 mille dollars par jour
de retard sont prévues la première
semaine de 400 mille dollars par jour
par la suite président d'un syndicat qui
représente les deux tiers des
travailleurs
michel trépanier est inquiet de
l'échéancier ça peut être possible
on va le voir dans les prochaines
semaines mon invité travailleurs ou
cette brute d'un pied de dénoncer des
choses si on veut prendre un raccourci
mais au cas où ce nouveau pont n'était
pas prêt ottawa a demandé un plan pour
garder ouvert le pont actuel jusqu'en
juillet 2019 et ça coûterait 10 millions
de dollars le gros du travail a été fait
avec les poutres extérieures sur le pont
champlain
puis là on est vraiment dans une mode de
gestion de risque de baisser les risques
en phase terminale le vieux pont
champlain a déjà coûté 330 millions de
dollars en travaux préventifs depuis
l'automne 2013
ici jean sébastien cloutier radio-canada
m'ont rien